so you gained weight and space I gained
weight I really liked the food man good
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean if you had it pretty much an
unlimited supply of macaroni and cheese
yeah but definitely common like a
freeze-dried little buzz yeah it's
dehydrated oh is that what it is but
though it's good it's macaroni and
cheese one of my favorites that's
dehydrated also shrimp cocktail shrimp
cocktails excellent dad I think I don't
I don't know if we have stats on this
you guys are living pretty high on the
hog oh yeah yeah yeah read that
astronaut ice cream they sell no yeah it
looks like cotton candy I had I don't
know what it is it looks like cardboard
yes and every once in a while I get like
coerced into eating it for you know kid
thing or something we don't eat that
stuff in space we have really good food
yeah chocolate fudge cake for example
it's a very good dessert if you like I
have to call it cardboard which is what
that ice cream is or chocolate fudge
cake you going for the chocolate fudge
cake yeah kids love that too that
astronaut ice cream stuff though yeah
well kind of kids man only they're
stupid let's be there eating that stuff
dolt sorry you know we're not gonna get
fooled
we've lived like no better than
cardboard ice cream yeah there's no good
but the food is really good
wait so here's the thing because I'm
trying to figure it out yeah
aren't you supposed to lose weight in
space most people don't gain weight in
space I was one of only two people when
I got back after my first flight in
eight and there your physical and they
take your blood pressure of course all
your vitals in a way you it was like oh
my god it was you're like a eureka he
gained weight they got me in a little
bit heavier than when they put me on the
spaceship what a couple weeks earlier
how was that yeah so I think there's a
couple one is is that I was in really
good shape when I let on my space
flights the best shape I was ever in my
life so I think I was kind of low and
then when I got to space you know you
don't need very much one of these you
don't need very much especially you
don't feel very very good you know I
didn't feel very well
right am i stuck we have a bit of a
stomach awareness who's your whole
system is getting used to it up there
your vestibular system works on gravity
when we're here on earth so tell
we're we're right-side up we're
accelerating we're moving around as we
move our head if we're running driving a
car you're accelerating right all that
stuff works in concert with your with
your eye movements with your vision now
what happens is when you're in space and
your vestibular system stops working
because it works on gravity your your
brain gets a bit confused because of the
stimulus system is saying you're
perfectly still but your eyes are saying
you're moving so the first couple days
you don't feel very well so do you feel
yourself actually in in freefall around
the nose you're in default
right you are you go and you're going
around our planet at 17,500 miles an
hour but really no sensation of speed
other than you know you look you look up
on this watch out you know here
California and then we hit Miami in ten
minutes goes by you know that's going
really fast right right but but you
don't feel it you don't need no wind
resistance there's nothing it's just you
know just this motion so how about
exercise you guys that's why I gained
all that weight the issue is in in space
if you're up there for longer periods a
couple weeks like I was up there with
Michael with my astronaut friends not
that bad if you didn't exercise but we
still exercise everybody feel better of
course right so every day we got sunny
if we weren't space walking which is
like that's literally done yeah you were
doing something exercise mainly riding
an exercise bike is what we have on
board the shuttle these guys on the
Space Age men and women on the space
station if you're up there for that
amount of time that that the missions
are currently in six months so picture
if you like on like super duper bed rest
meaning absolutely nothing it's even
worse than bed rest you laid down for
don't try this by the way but if you
just lay down for six months straight
and didn't need to anything oh my god
here's my dream yeah exactly but it
wouldn't be so such a good idea to get
up right away after us six months so
when you're up there floating in space
you're not even using any of your
muscles no load at all is being placed
under your muscles so you bone
Lode I mean that no force there's no
force and that's because you're
weightless but you're weightless so
right now even what we're doing by
moving our hands by sitting up straight
as best we can getting up and walking
around a little bit we are doing a
little bit right there keeps keeps us
not doesn't gonna sort of keep us in
shape but it will prevent us from being
totally deteriorated after after like
you would be in space so in space while
you're doing that if you know doing the
body adjust to that environment in that
way if you're not doing anything so
you'll you'll go to go through bone loss
your bones will become much weaker oh
really and you'll go through muscle loss
and even your heart will shrink your
heart some muscle right it's not going
to pump as hard if you just lay it
around all the time so by exercising
you're keeping your muscles strong and
your your bones strong and everything's
working really well and we've gotten
pretty the issue with it though is that
it requires a lot of time so it's a
two-hour exercise period every day six
days a week every day six days a week
yeah - well and and that isn't yep
that's because the the benefits of
exercising aren't as intense because you
have no force and acted upon you right
so you have so we do but so we do they
have a there's a treadmill and there's
an exercise bike on this on the space
station there's also a resistive
exercise device oh yeah yes so you get a
resistive exercise which is like
weightlifting right and because you can
take 600 pounds and though you and I can
you just play catch with it
nice right that's a lot we can't do that
you remember right right but in space
since you won't have the weights right
you have mass but not weight you have
mass no wait wait but right so sorry
because you have any gravity further
actually weigh something so big barbells
and dumbbells aren't going to help you
so what we what we use is this this
resistive exercise device which works on
Springs pulleys kind of like the you
know a thera-band right yeah you know
that resistance exactly so so this
allows you to get a full body workout
you're you can do squats and curls and
bench and everything else like you would
but you do with this special machines
and now I just want to go to space to
lift 600 pounds so just a bent 600
rounds a SWAT can we handle these big
instruments weighing 300
like there were nothing got to be
careful they may get away from me easily
too so you gotta be careful with that
stuff
we have forces in that enacted upon us
inter on earth why don't they just
create that up they're like what was
that Space Odyssey 2001 yeah they're
rotating rotating there took that that
requires that would be cool right but I
that requires a really big spaceship or
it requires a lot of room I had a friend
of mine in grad school who had disis
when he had his idea and equipment II
built was a centrifuge that you could
sleep on so you wouldn't waste any time
during the day and you would be II
responded was at the center of it so you
wouldn't get this court right like that
wig out right so and it would rotate you
in and des that rotation is like
sleeping in a in a centrifuge and that
would put force on your body in that
would help but that was pretty big man
as that was really big
the bed was big the baguette it was you
have to put a bed means it's got a
rotate do you a lot of room for that
right right right so it's a little and
impractical it was like a localised
artificial gravity and Byron erect yeah
but you could produce an artificial
gravity environment I wrote a ting them
enough I you know that would that would
probably be a good idea yeah I don't
know what that would be like I think
because if you're rotating someone I
mean he had it was during sleeping but
you know for a room to be spinning I
think you need a really big room or a
lot alcohol a lot of room to be spinning
I think I think you're really neat
because afraid like we were in a
rotating room I think that would be a
little disconcerting yeah without a
doubt
yeah so artificial gravity is probably
not something we're gonna see then you
know if our yeah probably probably now
let's say figure out a better way to do
the transportation mode is the other
thing if you can get places more quickly
then you don't have to worry about
waiting around but when we get to
planets like if you're even on the on
the moon you have one-sixth gravity more
as you have one-sixth gravity so you
have a little bit of gravity there which
is very helpful but it's you got to be
able to withstand the voyage there
there's zero so on the missions I was on
going to Hubble on the shuttle right
which by the way you repaired the Hubble
ID I was one of those
you were dad was to you guys out there
and you had two other times we had
warning our ability of to spacewalking
teams right are out there you know
taking turns going out five days in a
row on both of my missions that's why
yeah so repairman its basement so you
will kind of key like we're going on a
car with boxing gloves that's pretty
much it is
people ask me astronomy questions right
yeah they ask me like my neighbors I'd
be like putting out the garbage and I go
hey Mike and Mike what they're you know
tonight isn't it true that Martin just
like as a question for you know Neil or
one of those you know Mars is over here
and that's the only time in 300 years
that it's over then Venus is there and
we're gonna see some other star come out
over there and I'm like I don't know
Hubble did it should I go yeah I worked
I don't look through the telescope is it
so yeah I grew a repairman up there
that's already you're way too modest man
a repairman I'm an astronaut repairman
look you say that I can fix almost
anything when it's inside of a spaceship
that's the problem is that now without
the space should I know it's like not
wearing a suit you can't if I want to
fix the sink I got to get a helmet on
this is I'm so used to doing it all
right keep your science capsule on
because the spinning doesn't stop here
for more on weight mass gravity and
subtropical force check out brilliance
centripetal force quiz it's part of the
classical mechanics course that gets
into explaining the core principles of
physics and applies them to real-world
uses like rockets and space and space
stations and drones and 0gm more if
you're the type of person who hears
scientific facts and wonders hey how
they figure that out then brilliant is
right for you it walks you through
scientific and mathematical problems
guiding you step-by-step at your own
pace
so you can sign up for free at brilliant
org slash start topic and get access to
weekly puzzles and brainteasers
but if you're one of the first 782
people to subscribe to our annual plan
which gives you access to all the
courses across a variety of subjects
including outer space and zero-g you
won't receive 20% off your annual fee
for life oh do you have a catchphrase
like zippity-doo-dah
[Music]